good morning Millennials 10:31
we're a little late a.m. Eastern Time
and Claudia you know really what you
guys thought no but I work a good thing
I know they probably thought I don't
know what did you guys think let us know
but we are officially we can finally
announce that we are going to be taking
over for Access Hollywood on the cma red
carpet so our Genki little instagram
show last year which was a huge success
if you haven't seen some of the footage
it is like the messiest but most premium
thing ever like we just didn't know like
what was gonna happen and it turns out
that like Nashville and just the Country
Music Association really respects the
hell out of us and every celebrity no
matter how big or small like stood by
our booth and like we just didn't know
what to do because we thought no one was
gonna walk by and it was so great and
even you know it was so great that it
caught the eye of some I don't know some
some investors yes yes and now we're
breaking the big leagues some big-time
magazine editor Jenna rink was watching
yeah
so we will be like what she saw we will
be streaming live on Access Hollywood
Facebook and YouTube pages it's gonna be
so easy for you guys to watch we will
make sure you have all the links before
we're going live at five-thirty and
we're just gonna keep going until you
know Karlie Kloss finally agrees to be
on our show it's true I'm so excited and
I'm so like nervous because the great
thing about our show in general
especially our red carpet extravaganza
is there's no structure there's no
format you never know what's gonna
happen a lot of it just hinges on our
established relationships and our
fangirl um experience experiences it
would be like if you put two of like the
biggest fans of like Taylor Swift like
in the reputation room in the reputation
room with a camera and interview asking
her all the questions that her fans want
to know like right not like you know
what inspired your album yeah far too
often are the people on the red carpet
like not actually fans and the people
that they're talking to and they think
they have script they get a binder
before but right sure's of everyone who
their spouses are and like what they
posted on Instagram in the past year I
mean they're talking points like singles
that are coming out albums that are
coming out we got that binder I'm gonna
throw it in the trash Kelsea Ballerini
was ever a nice to you at Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show and if so who wasn't
yes that's like what I want to know who
are you most excited to see I think
right now the comb
and all because I just I have such a
place in my heart for them
nobody zero and let us manage her Cappy
who's like a big toaster every time he's
mentioned on the show like you know what
I always hits us up but I would I think
a lot like when we met Luke Holmes like
we did it cuz we were just like being
sleuthy and like we were became friendly
with Nicole I'm like we got backstage
and he's very legit it was at Madison
Square Garden like it was very like
everyone from the label like it was very
real and his manager is like you know
someone told me that this podcast I
listened to was talking about us and I'm
like look at us - little Instagram girls
like literally our podcast is making the
big leagues our podcast is making the
gleason like everyone like Luke where's
Luke home store managers girl he's
hooking up with is a toaster like
everyone is just being infiltrated by
toasters and we wouldn't have it any
other way he took me up with yeah Oh
member no no that's his girlfriend yeah
she no they're like a real good
boyfriend girlfriend because she came to
my show
oh they I think it must've been since
then because Jackie she is the most
gorgeous girl she came from the show
she's like I'm Hannah I'm like you are
Hannah from Alabama yeah she was like a
model like I thought Elle Ferguson was
on my stage I was like good for her yeah
um so just like I don't know the world
revolves around the morning shows and I
refuse to hear anything otherwise I'm
getting told they can't hear me as well
as my it's my Feaster I think it's a
hair thing okay it's also a sweatshirt
thing because we are going to the
airport yes straight from the show I
can't believe I have to be in another
Airport today and like as excited as I
am for my sister it's like the fact that
she's making me go to an airport again
is just truly unforgivable
can you not believe that you're about to
step onto a plane and end up in a
different land I can't actually because
it's all I've been thinking about
Olivia's bachelorette parties in Miami
this weekend we just have like a
fun-filled itinerary and I don't know if
I'm gonna make it as simple as that you
know we'll see we'll see where we're at
on Tuesday there's no show on no live
show on Monday but we will be releasing
the melissa gorga episode of the morning
toast podcast only so you will have that
to consume on your treacherous Monday
morning we would not leave you hanging
on a Monday no of course not
until the week after yeah I have
something to tell you like always want
to move quickly blend yes you have to
move to Charlotte instead I think what
you thought of Cleveland okay is what
Charlotte really is and I have to say
like I hate everywhere
like just as like a town I loved
Charlotte like first of all easy breezy
flight like an hour and a half but it
wasn't like the tiny plane that they
make you want to die okay just a premium
landing experience small airport in
Charlotte like nothing really to write
home about and it's really just like a
bigger
it's a spacious slower more low-key New
York like it is like there's tall
buildings and there's cabs but it's just
much more low-key and first of all the
the toasters in Charlotte like I didn't
know Charlotte was like one of our
places but it's one of a toaster hub it
is a hub it was for toasters NASCAR and
Michael Jordan and Duke University
that's Raleigh no there's just colleges
like all over North Carolina Oh like
from the longest ride sure what uh Wake
Forest sure and they were just like
sometimes it's difficult when you go to
a show that's very toasty because
everyone just wants to like talk the
whole time and I'm like performing you
know so Charlotte was the perfect mix of
just like the toasty is [ __ ] ever but
so respectful you know and it's nice
they respected the hell out of anything
with girl with no job it was so great
such great shows and I had the time of
my life because the points guy his
parent company is based in Charlotte so
he has to go there once a month and it's
like he literally bought 30 tickets for
like all of his employees and they came
and they were all just like cute young
fun beautiful people and we went out
afterwards to this bar and I had to do
the meeting great so I told the points
got to go and I would meet him
afterwards and he gave me like the name
of the place me and Margo get into an
uber and like we pull up to the suburbs
like we're like in the house and I'm so
confused and outside the house there's
like colorful light so I'm like okay
maybe we're in the right place and I go
in and it's like reminding me of Colgate
like it was truly a frat house
everybody's like a pool table and a
couple couches in a room and there's
some people hanging out and then
upstairs was like this bar and karaoke
and it was so premium so lit except for
the fact that the girl running the
karaoke like had a big head and like was
too in controlling that gave herself
songs there's something about being in
charge of karaoke that just makes a
monster out of people especially it's
like the person who is in charge also
thinks they have a good voice and like
was putting her songs at the front and I
requested so many songs that none of
them came and she like left to stand for
a while and was just like a laptop and
that like went and put my
on and she [ __ ] darted from the other
side of the bar she saw me and got on
the microphone started yelling I mean I
was like too [ __ ] up till I said I'm a
martyr just left shouldn't ruin my night
Hey yeah uh so I gotta go to Charlotte
and the weather's better there than
Cleveland oh it was 70 degrees Wow yeah
it was truly like a premium town and I
think when you think of Cleveland like
you have this vision like this utopia
yes but that actually is Charlotte okay
yeah good to know I'll be making my way
downtown down to the Caroline oh and
it's like downtown Charlotte it's called
Uptown like there's just so many little
quirky things quirky as hell but we're
happy to have you back yeah where to
take you back down south and like I'm so
busy this week but I'm really glad like
we figured it out that I only miss watch
oh right imma get a premium beauty
influencer to take my spot did she give
any good scoop on the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show why they were like
releasing photos from the show and all
the influencers were still getting ready
and I was like so confused oh I did well
because it was her her cells no I think
they did the show twice they always do
the show twice okay there's only got to
go to the second one
oh that makes sense yeah I mean that's
better for them anyway they don't have
to sit through two innings she were
talking about it before the show went
live so then I forgot to ask all the
same questions um but it's very
interesting they're being very revolve
and it's also competitive because the
revolve Awards are happening right now
so it's like how are there enough
influencers to fill a both place and
Olivia culpo is that neither how are
they're both enough influencers to fill
up both places
Olivia couples that neither and neither
are we like really know in Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show it was like truly
scraping the bottom of the barrel but it
comes to like local talent but I guess
we just didn't fit the wait minimum
which is fine like maybe next year ace
is really so crazy that I'm 2018 going
on 2019 they're still putting forward
the same image and they haven't been
like cancelled and there has yeah every
once awhile they get an Instagram
comment like show some real girls but
it's like we've just accepted that this
is this right before the first story so
do you want to jump into the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
I would love to we also need to recap
Sarto cycle but let's do that we have so
much to recap I feel like I haven't seen
you in the millennia I know even though
I truly show you my face times like all
day but we didn't catch up I don't know
we didn't catch up tell you about like
my nephews day how with your son
do let's go and do let's go nd hey let's
go
nd yo let's go cuz it's a chick night
it's alright
without do you know that there is a
toaster group called aunt and uncle
snitch S is for people who are answer
uncle's how many people earn it for its
new okay no not that early I'm in it
though yeah and it's just so interesting
all the and you know what I was thinking
about I remember when you first got CO
and I was making a joke about how there
really isn't a community for dog yeah me
and you were like you're in Iran yeah
and I have made a community for ants and
dog ants alike and you know what it's a
job that's never done you know what good
for you I'm so glad that we now have a
place to come together but I feel like
there's all these like self-help books
about the most [ __ ] things in the
world and I really can't believe that
there's not a book how do I hope he's
being a dog and I couldn't agree more
I'm officially turning off the comments
cuz I'm being too distracted I know but
the comments are being super helpful
today apparently someone's has a press
pass for us for the CMAs we just have to
check our facebook messages yeah we need
to get snitch like I'm I really like
sucked out everything I can get out of
Access Hollywood and the CMA like
institution and I'm no longer getting
what I need maybe snitch can get on the
red carpet by like being someone's arm
candy who is single chase rice oh yeah
he's like the only single country i but
also like according to hunter Hayes's
new song like he can't find love either
but I just I need I hope we talk to him
because I must ask him because the last
time we saw him he came on our show when
we were natural and he had the greatest
time and he brought his girlfriend who
was a toaster right and she had the
greatest time and braylon's friends with
her and apparently they're not even push
it I swear you'll in if they're still
together right because that song dear
God says oh my god it's such a good song
it's such a good song but why can't I
find any piece of love like it's it's
real it's dark it's dark so I wonder
maybe someone else wrote it but like if
I was his woman and he's singing why
can't I find a piece of love I'd be like
what the [ __ ] am I truly but like okay
so that's what I think about with Luke
Combs because he's in love with Nico
haki obviously and I know he wrote these
songs like 10 years ago
but in honky tonk highway there's a line
that like I'd love to sing but when I
say and I'm like damn that's not good
cuz he goes like this we got the bus and
the band
it's all about like life on the road
like it's a crazy night then we go home
we got the bus and the band and a
one-night stand
wait none it's down the road we're gonna
roll it in crank it to ten whiskey shots
till 2:00 a.m. then off to another show
but then it's back to my baby for a
couple days but I can only stay for so
long til that honky Tonk Howie's calling
me home so obviously like he brought
that before meting meeting Nico and I
think he was just like writing a song
like glorifying like life on the road is
like a guy with a guitar but every time
I sing that I'm like Pitts Hill for me
and Nicole Wow I know Wow his album now
is songs he wrote when he was on vine
right like all of his songs are so old
like his album now is also the suck he
was like engaged was he I don't have to
see my ex future mother-in-law anymore
yeah and then there's in another song um
she got the best of me she broke my
heart is beating this guitar every night
a different town she follows me around
so you get what's left with me and my
planner like it has been lit and I've
emailed to everyone who works in my team
I'm like do not send me anywhere
February 28th Luca Luca in New York solo
show we've seen him as a part of a tour
with three people which is annoying cos
like every one time it gets cut down
except for like the only person you
don't want to see Jason Aldean um and
I'm just looking for it's like a premium
night with Jessa me and Luke Holmes
maybe one of his band members are at
that song about having one-night stands
maybe maybe hopefully you know I think
like you can always like songs at face
value yeah and I don't worry about her
no me neither but you can't take songs
at face value because a lot of the times
it's just like a glorification or like a
romanticism of like something you think
right it's like you take one saw England
span right it doesn't mean like
everything you write happened to you
right okay here are the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast can't remember if we
already said it we did okay
first story Adriana Lima bids
tear-filled farewell to Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show Adriana Lima is
hanging up her Victoria's Secret Angel
wings after 20 years and God visibly
emotional as she walks her final vs
fashion show run
on Thursday dressed in a sheer sparkling
top light blue lingerie nude feathered
heels and wide feathered wings like okay
so not dressed at all right at a 37 year
old Brazilian model was naked naked the
37 year old Brazilian model naked stands
for heels the 37 year old Brazilian
model thank you
with shoes on 37 year old familia model
naked with feathers the 37 year old
Brazilian model received a standing
ovation as she made her way down the
catwalk for the last time she took a
deep breath and appeared to get
teary-eyed as she paused to make
thank-you gestures at the cheering crowd
as seen in a fan video quote dear
Victoria thank you for showing me the
world sharing your secrets and most
importantly not just giving me wings but
teaching me to fly and all the and all
the heart emoji to the best fans in the
earth and there's just like so many
things that happen at the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show in a channel Lima
retiring it's like not what I'm
concerned with homegirl has been on the
on the walk for 17 years like it's
enough going home
2007 teen years 17 years like there are
people who are as old as Adriana Lima's
career on the Victoria Secret like it's
enough her she's beautiful oh great
goodbye I want to talk about other
things okay I want to talk about the
dylan sprouse and the Barbara Palvin of
it all this Shake Shack about was it
sponsored I want to say no I want to say
no because I actually think they're
they're like too cool for that and I
feel like even if they offer to sponsor
it like they want to be like real with
people and yeah and like do stuff that's
relatable and it's not relatable if it's
fun right and also when it's like Shake
Shack it's like they're too big like you
would do it anyway like he was in bring
McDonald's like that's not funny right
you know I'm like I feel like Victoria's
Secret would have to like get a piece of
it and get it approved right um he cut
his hair and he is truly so hot do you
rather than call a for sure and he
always was even as it even as Zach yeah
no and Cody was a nerd for me he's
hotter than cool because like I hate
Jughead
right I'm trippin sons behind everyone
else 3 because I'm saving them up ok
yeah because it's like not that fun to
watch me tweak no and like I get my
heart racing and I don't know what
happens like I just wanna I want to
close the book I am now that we're not
doing after day like which is I can
watch Riverdale whenever the [ __ ] I want
and I've never been happier yeah until
it becomes like suspense so that I have
to watch every week like I'm
the barber barber cabin in the end the
junk sprouts of it all
dylan sprouse is so [ __ ] handsome and
like every picture i just love them
together i just can't believe he's tall
enough to be dating a supermodel he is
very tall I was thinking the same thing
because when they when she changed into
her after party outfit they took a
picture I was like oh it's not that much
shorter than her and like he'll be at
them if you can keep this up he'll be at
the Met Gala next year was he not there
this year
no just just the brow he should be at
the Met Gala like with her yeah no of
course not without her but like he is so
hot he should really like he could
really become like the next big male
model and that's what I think he should
focus on he models a lot really hmm
because he's like American boy like hot
but he's also like a little fashion you
know I think I'm just old because the
the brothers Sprouse do not do it for me
like I agree that Dylan is better like
does it a little bit more for me but
overall like I'm not interested oh no
over I think it's an age I do I don't
think it's a taste thing I think it's
like they feel like children to me or
like you can't see them as anything
other than that somebody's Jackie you
can't see them as anyone else than the
hotel lobby singers son's been carries
sons well I just love it and I want to
talk about Barbara Palvin for a minute
cuz homegirl has walked in the show many
a time and I never really took notice
start not gonna lie I really like didn't
like her like I just thought she was
just like oh he's getting things just
cuz like she was like you know yeah like
I don't know it just like I was only
thought to as a model she's in every
[ __ ] commercial like she just gets
everything and I never knew why yeah
she's like 10 million in certain
followers and I never understood why and
last night
snitch GM to me a photo of like the
photos come out before it's so weird I
want to talk about that structure as
well yes but this strategy homegirl
looked amazing and I don't think she's
ever looked the way that she does I
think she definitely gained weight but
like in the most positive way and I know
saying that has a negative connotation
but I mean it in a positive way I don't
know how else to say it then like she
looks so healthy in the most beautiful
way like out of all the bodies I saw I
want Barbara Palvin it's like she's the
most interesting to look at she looked
so good and I was like oh my god I never
noticed her before so this must be a new
thing and then I went to look at her
Instagram I'm like no no she has been
looking this way for like almost a year
she looks so good so healthy and like so
normal and relatable like that is a body
like I'll never have but like one like
maybe you know that
a body that you can put up on your
fridge eyes like inspiration I want to
look like that one guy she really nobody
elastic you don't put up some of the I
don't want to shame anyone some of the
other programs the bone models because
you're never gonna look like that nor
should be one I don't want to like what
I think like ever looks like that it
would mean that like I sent my hope like
send so much time and effort trying to
look like that that I wouldn't be happy
you know when I if I wanted to look like
that I mean I would want to be sad
yeah like when I've got like dream body
like if I could like I don't gonna hook
it up I would want combo of like Kate
Upton Barbara Palvin Camille Cossack
vibes yeah Kate Upton Kate Upton I'm
still pulling for her being pregnant on
the cover Victoria Margot told me that
we said that and I think it's the most
genius call said it with Margot yeah cuz
I'd ever heard that cuz like who else
would be on the cover they're always
trying to break barriers they had a
pregnant woman walk in their miami swim
we'd show and i just feel like and
whenever they don't know what to do they
put Kate Upton on and now she's pregnant
totally but the only the reason I think
that they wouldn't is cuz I guess
they're here to empower females
and they really like to come from like
this bikini thing to like a like a
movement but the majority of people who
buy that cover jerk off to it and
they're just not gonna jerk off to a
pregnant woman
you never know know like a couple freaks
people don't jerk off to the cover
though like the cover still has to be in
like newsstands right so it can't be
like full nudity and yeah it really is
crazy like Victoria's Secret is like
went one way like we will not change hmm
ever and Sports Illustrated's the
complete opposite mm Sports Illustrated
so I was thinking the other day it's
like if I could be a part of like
they're both like these institutions
that models like die for a career
benchmark Emile kostikova says like it
was always my dream to be in Sports
Illustrated like that's the thing like
some girls like they just want to be
angels like a 1001 angel it's these
benchmarks for models that like once you
make it's like a career highlight and I
was thinking like which one would I want
to be a part of and I can't decide I
mean I would only have one option
realistically but just like if they both
offered me the contract where would I go
because with betrayus you could there's
more prestige there's more Instagram
followers more money there's more money
there's more special there's more
glamour but with Sports Illustrated
there's just more like sexy and like
more fun fun and real and like I think
there's more longevity in terms of
chrissy teigen was yeah he nog didn't
like Hannah Davies like they really have
a way of like projecting people's
careers past being models so I think I
would go Sports Illustrated I think I
would too and I just like what they
stand for more look at Hunter McGrady as
part of their rookie like contest yeah
who's plus-size model I just I can't
believe that like it's 2018 and
Victoria's Secret hasn't reached out to
Ashley Graham and she has like um spoken
so poorly of them and rightfully so so
that they wouldn't reach out to her but
like someone someone a Iskra I can't I
can't campaign enough for Iskra Laurens
no I know you love her and it doesn't
even have to be someone who's a
plus-size model like what about just
like Robyn Lawley yeah rap I saw a girl
on in the Sports Illustrated video like
someone who was a fan I was on Dolores
katanas Instagram and I guess MJ is a
fan of the show and recorded a video
with one of the models who is also a fan
of the show she was like Dolores like I
love you I remember you from Season one
when you're just hanging out
that's again she had like the most
incredible body like biggest hits like
just real looking and it's like I want
to see that walking down the runway
shaking that saying I couldn't agree
more land it's like so stupid these
girls don't even have boobs like and
they're wearing bras it's so stupid like
a magic ain't up to him like it would be
so much better like she fits no it'd be
so much more interesting to look at and
then there's also the strategy the press
strategy of it all where it's like
everything last night was photographed
published live streamed etc so why do we
need to tune into the show in December I
had in turn in last year and it was like
a liberating thing whereas like in high
school it used to be like this thing
everyone watching songs and thing and it
was like literally three seconds of
actual walking and other was like music
videos of songs they didn't know the
words to write and I'm just I'm really
like not interested I'm not interested I
won't be watching and snitch DMV a video
of someone
butch Inge the song butchering the Sachi
but butcher boat okay
butchering this is me I do I know who it
was I don't know who to blame um but no
and by the way this is me does not apply
to Victoria's Secret model well that's
what I was gonna say so the whole
message of the song this is me I don't
know if anyone ever looked up the lyrics
who works at Victoria's Secret we can
we'll give you a little
no look I am brave it is brave season
I am bruised I'm who I'm meant to be
this isn't he take me or leave me all my
flaws embrace it
look how cuz here I come and I'm
marching on to the beat I job the only
my own drop this standards of society
sets for me I embrace I'm Bruce I'm who
I meant to be this is scenes so like
it's it's just like the work like you
know that if they want it to be more
accurate
they should have sing it just like I'll
turn a couple of the lyrics they should
have been like I am NOT brave I am not
bruised this is not who I was meant to
be this is not my face
this is not my nose these are not my
lips this is me this is me it's just
stupid like don't butcher a perfectly
good song with a positive message for
your ulterior motives
I'm like such a hater when it comes to
victorious with your fashion show and I
don't care and the pictures I'm seeing
like they were putting like these girls
work all year model squad you see like
Devon Windsor gym every day every day
they put these girls in pants jumpsuits
long-sleeve pants with long sleeve
jumpsuits like for what I don't know and
I just can't believe we weren't invited
you know some of the outfits were truly
like oh it's like tragic and I don't
know how idea why don't they go with no
clothes right I don't know what the
themes were I think when Kelsey
ballerina in the chainsmokers performed
it was like this gilded golden vibe
Kelsey looked great I loved her dress
I'm excited to see the performances I
saw a clip of Shawn Mendes singing he's
saying lostinjapan and maybe it was like
a hard uq themed okay I don't know I
just made that up but like why didn't he
sing in my blood like maybe he did as
well they should have done like a
carryin stained team where where they
where they where they show how durable
their underwear is because everyone has
their period and he's singing in my
blood now that is a message I can give
on vertical integration do they also own
Playtex something to show the tampon
string down their leg or someone just
dressed up it's like a full tampon you
know imagine having your period and
walking with Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show you know those girls don't get
their periods cuz they're so skinny like
when you get to a certain weight you
don't get your period
imagine your day one of your period at
the Victoria's Secret right like maybe a
big
but they're always wanting to go behind
the scenes to learn more about the
models like talk about that how do you
got back straight your bike
oh they're all on birth control problems
and they probably just moved their sugar
pills or whatever yeah with SIBO pills
whatever time yeah you can make control
when you get your period placenta pills
not placebo let's see no placebo oh yeah
placenta pills let's see about meaning
you take them so you remember to take
your pill every day but it doesn't have
the hormones and it's a sugar pill I'm
getting like but no they wouldn't take
that because it has sugar oh right you'd
see it when they walk down the aisle
whatever it's called because we ever hit
backstage at Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show I want to show of hands who has
their period yeah
and who who like genetically modified
their body who is a non GMO who got rid
of their period oh yeah just like I hate
the whole institution and I'm sorry okay
next story a little bit of a twist here
someone I don't think we've ever Oh
iPads tweaking now is it page six it's
no no no page six fixed their their bug
but someone I don't think we've ever
spoken about on the show here we go ah I
don't mean no okay Adam driver has
secretly been a dad for two years Wow in
this Star Wars franchise the lineage of
Adam drivers character as the son of Han
Solo is a major plot point but drivers
fans have widely speculated about
whether he himself is a dad off-screen
now sources tell page six that driver
does indeed have a two-year-old son with
wife Joanne Tucker but despite the fact
that driver has become a Hollywood Big
Shot it's somehow escaped the attention
of the public pals of the actor and his
wife say that the family members have
posted about Tucker's pregnancy on their
private Instagram feeds one post was
also an image of Tucker with her sister
who was also pregnant at the time and
the caption sisters nearly matching
everything hashtag baby shower x2 it's a
Silvana how like the world
describes Adam driver as like the Han
Solo Star Wars whatever legacy where
it's like I've never seen that movie and
he'll always be like the only guy who
was realistic with Lena Dunham in girls
you know of course yes
and they really should should call him
that I didn't know this I can't lie like
I'm not shocked I don't really care I
don't even know he was married like I
know someone who's invested in pop
culture and knows who Adam driver is
like I I'm just not interested so it's
not that like he got away with it it's
just that we don't care like I don't
know I think he got away with it and now
that I think about it he really has like
a wonderful level of suburb where it's
like he's making my
hand over fist esteemed in his Cranwell
respective posts SNL once a season oh
yeah but like the paparazzi don't shove
a lens up his [ __ ] and his character
or they don't shove a lens up his wife's
vision right like that's really nice to
do like the the Kraft right without the
flip side their job there's a couple
people out in Hollywood who have
maintained like really good levels of
like wealth and fame without like
selling their souls and like not being
able to do normal things like the
grocery store right like um SIA well
yeah but she's like doing it on purpose
like Adam driver I don't know I can't
think of anyone else but you know like
I'm Jennifer Lawrence like doesn't
really get spotted that much [ __ ]
now this is the work she does with her
man no no but when you live in New York
it's like a much more low-key lifestyle
for celebs like you there's not as much
paparazzi like at the 7-eleven elses
right so if you are a celebrity who
lives in New York I automatically think
you're just more down-to-earth and like
you have a better like point of view
then you'd then the people who like move
to LA and like live in estates in
Silverlake but I would do it I'm not
gonna lie if you got like so famous
would you want living like a mansion in
LA or a penthouse in New York assuming
like that we all moved with you it's not
like about family got it I wouldn't
wanna live in a penthouse because I do
not like Heights and I get vertigo being
way too high up so maybe a townhouse but
then that takes away the security of a
building um I think I would I would say
New York just say no in a regular
building in a big building so I'm more
anonymous you know I meant like a nice
apartment in New York or a nice house in
LA is what I mean I want a nice
apartment in New York with a nice house
in Long Island so I couldn't get my
Cleveland vibes what I need I got it and
your grassy grassy roots my grassy
knolls got it by the way there is a
music festival in Dallas someone told me
about that I think we need to go to I
think we need to go to Luke Romans is
playing right Sam hot Lauren Elena we
literally just like I'm gonna fried
stuff Tex Lorna enough for her birthday
I'd like my do it yesterday yesterday
almost like a minute late um we should
just really get a tour bus and follow
Luke Holmes's around because I'll just
go wherever he is but yes I would love
to go to that and it's like the weekend
of like snitch's birthday so yes it was
made for it'll be a birthday
extravaganza may the force be with you I
hate when people make stupid jokes like
that
um I just did
speaking of estates in LA Kim Kardashian
was forced to evacuate her home amid a
wildfire oh yes I heard about this
across the highway this morning the
Keeping Up with the Kardashians star was
just returning from a trip when she saw
flames from the window of her private
plane once she touched down she had to
quickly gather her belongings and head
to safer grounds quote pray for
calabasas she wrote on Instagram just
landed back home and I had one hour to
pack up and evacuate our home I pray
everyone is safe
Kardashian also shared footage of the
plane and fire departments responding to
the emergency firefighters are arriving
short in another post thank you for all
that you do for us oh my god like it's
just so crazy cuz like that is something
as people who live in New York like I'll
never have to worry about like we worry
about other things like I don't know
like someone like I'm groping you on the
subway like there's just be different
issues so like fires are crazy it's like
biblical it is and I always get like so
sad thinking about all the animals like
who like either don't know what's going
on or like die or like I've to leave
their homes like it's so sad they've
spent all year like building this nest
it's so sad and try as I may like I
can't understand like the wildfires are
being started by arsonists what that's
what I heard somewhere like um that's
one case where people start fires I
thought it said it's so dry there's no
rain the friction of the plants and the
sticks like yes and then everything else
is so dry that it can't stop spreading
right I think there are cases of both
this is just like I don't know why I
like gives me desperate housewives'
vibes you know yeah it's just so it's so
crazy it is so crazy and it's like it's
2018 like I got the air no like it's
biblical I need to still watch that
movie with miles teller and then I think
I'll have a way better understanding of
like what goes on it's so crazy how like
movies really teach us teach us so much
like captain Phillips you know I really
learned a lot about being the captain
Security's in shipping cargo across the
Atlantic total and piracy right ya know
this is just very sad very sad and it's
like it's like sad Kim had to gather her
Chanel coats in her private jet but like
it's not like him know what's up the
fact that Kim is being affected by it
just makes me sad to know how many that
means so many more people are being
affected by it who aren't in her
position to
turn the plane around totally but it
also is like damn at the end of the day
we're all people like when we're dead
we're dead
you know I'm gonna give a [ __ ] at how
many Instagram followers you had
unfortunately take them with you you
can't take them with you even though if
I could I would need 5,000 more cuz then
I'm at 3 million so what everyone just
like hooked me up and tell your friends
to follow me
totally like if everyone who's watching
right now tells a friend I mean if their
friends don't follow you like why are
you even friends with them yeah I'm like
talking to the wrong people there
already right you need to get on like
Joe Rogan I need to get on Joe Road yeah
and he should get on here what is Joe
Rogan so if everyone is obsessed with
your brakes comedy podcast it's always
number one it's always number one I
believe he livestreams like we do on
YouTube and it's also a podcast and he's
like he's great and funny and it's like
political I don't think so cuz he's
under comedy but I guess politics can be
funny and sad but like when Roseanne got
fired like that was the first interview
she did so I thought it was like a
political show so I don't know I know
nothing about and Ilana yeah I don't
know we haven't talked about Elon in a
while tragic I hope that means that he's
taking the time for himself that he
because he had to step down as chairman
yeah but I think that's like um informal
unerringly thing you know like have you
caught up I'm younger yet no okay so I
can't make the comparison I've been
waiting to make but you know I'm very
patient and I'll wait you are derivation
by the way I was skinny confidential
yesterday um no you didn't she was great
she really is just like such a prick
knowledge full of knowledge I need to
think of all so we went through Oprah's
Favorite Things and I asked her like I
got her pulse on some of the Beauty ones
and it sounds like it sold all bs and
like now I really am skeptical of
Oprah's paper do you think it's
sponsored I feel like she definitely she
definitely gets uh kickbacks from the
affiliate and Romo codes and I feel like
there definitely are a few things in
there that she's being paid to push but
I there has to be some things that she
inherently loves and that inspired me
someone wrote in the toast after dark
we're gonna do a patreon episode of our
favorite things like the things that I
can't live without that are amazing
gifts and that you should either get
through yourself or get for a loved one
this holiday season um okay well I feel
like I've never I've only met her once
when we did her podcast and her husband
are like so cute and like mogul by its
mobile vine it's just so funny how like
there are people like in our network
that like you exclusively like no
because they fill in for me
I supposedly know cuz like they feel
them for you you know totally and so
when there's crossover it's it's fun so
truly the greatest show this is the
greatest show Kelly Clarkson never
enough cover up came out today Matt I
enjoyed it I only listen to it once I
just love her voice and I just love that
they're doing this for us and here's
here's the problem she knew she was
getting paid fourteen million dollars to
do the voice it's not enough never never
enough this is the double-edged sword
when it comes to an album like this yeah
because either they change it too much
either they just sing the song as it's
written and it's just like a cover of a
song right it's not interesting or they
change it and then it's like glad you
changed a perfect song yeah so I don't
know like so I'm just trying to enjoy
and trust Pasek and Paul that they know
what they're doing okay but did you
register yesterday
okay so registering like I'm just a
slowest person in the world yeah but I
so I registered a while back but
yesterday I finally built my wedding
website treachery no not really because
I used as Ola oh I didn't use Ola you
did okay I well I only I didn't even
look at other options I just like Zola
is the one they weren't shark tank now
they were I think so
we have to I don't start taking the
second we've so much to talk about I
don't want to speak out of turn but I
think Zola was on charging okay well I
understand why because they do so much
they do registries they do like anything
you need it's and they also do anyway I
mean yeah honeymoon and so I right now
at this age where I need a website so I
went on I was like ready to just like
[ __ ] do not be well [ __ ] and it was
so easy like they have all these
templates I like to do is like fill in
our names dates added some pictures they
even had and then you can change like
the names like Zilla registry calm slash
like Jackie and Zach so I did that and
then they were like do you want to
purchase a domain right like i bought a
domain name through Zola and they'll
automatically linked and it really
needed so oh my god because like when I
have to make our stupid morning toast
like website like I had to like I was on
all these websites so like I was just
not meant to be on that's really nice I
didn't know that they did that know it
they do that would you buy I
Oh Jackie Oh calm would you do I did but
um I was gonna like change a bit private
oh sorry oh my god it doesn't know
actually no tell everyone like literate
older mother wedding website and some
amazing girls about me my salt shakers
cute yeah Sachi Oh calm it's not live
yet so I'm still working out some
details but you I had already registered
so you can add your existing registry or
you can register through there and you
can register for like the crazy stuff
like Airbnb and you can start a
honeymoon sign so yes they work that's
that's how they got started because they
were on shark tank like years ago but as
like a honeymoon fund like just like uh
yeah like that's how they started I
believe honeymoon fund is such a cute
idea except like I just have some really
expensive things on my registry that I
want that are taking part
I literally registered for the most wild
item for you know like Christofle silver
well then what silver where did you
register thorne um like my I got
everyday silverware which was just like
nice [ __ ] from Bloomingdale's and then I
did like China I don't know Chris Savile
did a collaboration with Karl Lagerfeld
of like this big egg of oh yeah and so
professions have it hi egg it's a lot
like four figures yes oh my god yeah I
don't know if I'll be getting any ones
feeling crazy generous anyways you can
have your own wonderful experience with
Zola I have by going to Zola calm slash
toast Zola calm slash toast and check it
out and you will be so glad that you did
vol a I'm like I'm I'm in Pittsville
that I didn't use it yeah it really just
like I've been treading I've been
putting this off for so long and I'm so
glad that we like got in touch with Zola
and now ya think I was in the shade I
have one thing on my list knocked off
just ninety mile or to go yeah oh my god
like torque sure never ends when it
comes to weddings wedding season is upon
us
it never ends I hope it ends when you
get married oh yeah it does yes I'm
sorry
wedding treachery never ends until you
marry did you get a new set of issues
once you're married thank you cards did
you ever send out thank you cards um
okay so like the next day when I we
opened all the checks like the people
who like really showed out financially
like got immediate handwritten cards and
then like a month later I like literally
do not want to do it and Ben's mom found
out that we did in and she was like
mortified and she wrote them for us Wow
and she is like so artistic do you think
she had extra help with her twin Oh
probably she's very artistic so she
like prints her own stationery like she
has like she has a full craft closet in
her house like she was a perfect person
to do because she know she made them
like so nice nice and then people think
like I put time and effort into it and
now they're finding out that I didn't
write and it was just a ban her twin
yeah okay this next story I saw
yesterday but I saved it for today for
one year here okay I really want to get
your take on it oh they're gonna be
really pleased with pretty little thing
who are now showing outfits on two
different sized models okay so I know
this okay for those of you who don't a
pretty little thing clothing range that
Haley Baldwin is fronting is being
praised by consumers for showing the
products on two different size models
the hashtag every body in PLT campaign
makes it super super easy for people to
imagine what the clothes would actually
look like on their own bodies and fans
are now calling on four other retailer
retailers to follow suit so they modeled
each piece in the collection on you know
a small purse on a plus-size model and a
fit model a traditional model whatever
okay so I recently placed an order for
pretty little thing and I noticed that
they were doing it on some of the items
and I was like I didn't think of it it's
like a big deal I'm like oh damn what a
pleasant experience you know and then I
had an unpleasant experience because I
had to return two items but they make
you pay for shipping back to New Zealand
which is more than the actual items so I
had to keep them okay so they have other
issues to work out yeah but I feel like
this is really the future it seems like
that's the thing about great ideas it's
like all it takes is one no all it takes
is one and when it happens it seems like
a no-brainer because that's how
necessary it is but it's like a huge
deal this is revolutionary and I really
hope it starts a chain reaction it's
just so weird that like Haley Baldwin is
at the forefront of the collection like
you know she had nothing to do with it
and I couldn't care less that they're
modeling it on like a realistic-looking
model she just like put her name on it
and like it's cashing those checks so
like good for her for like bringing eyes
to MIT but like lol that like she's
being hailed it's like the UH like the
innovator by name is like all over this
ring she had absolutely nothing to do
with it
but you know she could use a little good
press she's like such a weird model cuz
like is she a model like she honestly
like she's not in a Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show all of her friends are
she's not that tall so like she doesn't
do runway she doesn't walk ever in
Fashion Week but like she'd models for
guests like what is she she's like a
pretty girl she's like editorial I know
she's commercial yeah
no but she should do Sports Illustrated
yeah I feel like yeah illustrate doesn't
discriminated based on height cuz like
you can't even tell that ya know and
they don't really do runway except for
like their one show that they just
started right and like you can be
pregnant and walking in so you be she'll
say oh can be hello are you can be Haley
Baldwin I'm sure they make repair no
they really should be like now that
she's like a wife she's like gonna be a
stay-at-home well she needs to because
her husband can stop crying that like he
definitely needs her atever know what is
going on
I don't know and and like do you see
that they were with his mom at like the
Holiday Inn Express
like once yeah waiter like the mom was
staying at Holiday Inn Express and it's
like was mom Justin's and it's like
jessamy burrs mom is staying at Holiday
Inn Express what it's coming no wonder
why she doesn't like Haley because like
look where she brought him why I don't
know I saw that I was with the crying I
don't know it's like everyday in Miami
he's crying oh maybe we'll see them
crying oh my god we would live stream
they they also like step out like they
live as if they're normal people when
they're not like right but at the same
time like they like in private scenarios
she stopped at a light and they're in
the car and he's crying and someone's
filming it like you don't think in your
own car while you're driving and you
stop at a light for two seconds that you
can cry in peace and you can like so
they have literally no privacy even in
their own car but they also like sit on
benches and it was so weird she
literally she wasn't even controlling me
Meredith Blake honestly like he's at the
point where he needs a Meredith Blake
yeah like someone just to whip him into
shape but a be she's alright every time
can you cancel a crying like drug addict
stop know what's going on anyways here
for a pretty little thing and I just I
wanted to bring up the story because I
hadn't seen it before I was looking for
stories but I'm glad that you that you
had yeah no I I hadn't seen it as a news
story that no people were like
applauding it I was just like had a
pleasant experience and didn't think
anything other which is the way that
life should be but it's not because I
ordered over we could go close for this
met bachelorette party from boohoo and
they never came so now I have Saudi
Miami clothes arriving on Saturday that
I don't [ __ ] need in New York you can
still be a sought here but we got plenty
of it's cold there's a community for
thoughts
yeah Margo spearheads it they have
weekly meetings okay they didn't buy no
story little business every day 1111 for
like the first time ever
well I have to work on the new wish I'll
have to think long and hard about let's
go shopping
yeah Disney's new streaming service will
be called Disney Plus Disney's upcoming
streaming service will be called Disney
Plus CEO Bob Iger announced on a call
for investors Thursday I can't believe
we weren't on the call and I can't
believe that like a phone call is now
news how did people find out that was in
Seoul Ernie oh okay no I don't know or
it's like a call and then they do a
press release it's like a public thing
just weird like they got their
information from like a tapped phone
call there's a mole it's interesting I
never thought of it there's a mole on my
back and then Disney the word mole is
very multifaceted it really is but in
all ways it's like in every movie
there's like yeah it's like there's a
mom like I just got a removed like in
odds and powers yes Mona Mona Mona I
want to chop it up and make it into like
a male the service is expected to hit
the US market late next year and will
include content from the Disney flagship
brand as well as Pixar Marvel Star Wars
and National Geographic I just wonder if
this means that they're pulling all
their other Marvel dizzay off of like
Netflix and Amazon just so people have
to download this separately I hope this
also includes I have the Disney Channel
app so I hope that this content will
stream through there in which case I'll
be happy to to fork over some cash for
it and I will how do I work over there
some cash if they had like even Stephens
that's so raven hannah montana
that's cory in the house like all if
they had vintage Disney on demand on
their streaming service I would be down
he comes the color of friendship the
luck of the Irish make a wish upon a
star a model behavior smart house
terrible actually every silly watch it
it and it's like not nearly as cool in
2018 I mean like that house doesn't even
technologically sound to any more houses
like like oh like yeah Pat who was like
the Siri like she was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
totally um also like Disney owns ABC
will this include ABC contract perhaps
Wives I could go for every season of
bachelor bachelorette since season one
just for housewives Desperate Housewives
ESPN right like is this a hearse thing
like his or her Disney as a part of hers
right no Disney is the
is the top yeah but they own they might
own Hearst which owns espn/abc like no
Disney owns ABC ESPN it's all the same
so I just want all of it so now I own it
yeah ger also said the service will
include all the company's new theatrical
releases starting with the next year's
movie slate the studio has several major
releases in 2019 including a Marvel
Avengers movie live-action adoptions of
Dumbo Aladdin Lion King and frozen - a
sequel to the breakout 2013 animated hit
ok
live-action adoption adaption of Dumbo
like isn't that just National Geographic
like how are you gonna bring elephants
to life
wait live-action live actually is like
Beauty and the Beast but that's what's
gonna say maybe it's like set in the
real world but just like the elephants
are animated and if they're harming real
elephants for Dumbo like I just can't I
can't with everyone being so insensitive
I don't even understand how the Lion
King was gonna work you know yeah but
they have an amazing cast I'm sure they
figured it out but it's like baby I'm
gonna be walking talking real lions oh
good call you know it's confused but
like maybe they'll be like the Lumiere
but Lumiere was like an animated
candlestick like it was it was a
candlestick not real but the little
stick was real um right but like the
point is that it's a talking candlestick
that's crazy a talking lion is is
impossible because no one's gloomy or
complaining
well the flat was entertaining I Ching
wicked dance after all miss misses
friends and it's all in here fingers
neighbors we're on two different verses
go on and lift your menu from the mat
and then you'll be a guest be our guest
be our guest anyways this seems like an
opportunity buy some stock in Disney
because I feel like this is an Amul
that's in tune with what's necessary
it's evolving with the time jazzy is
always good stock like I think like as
children we were given like Disney stock
like for a dollar you know yeah I get
two always been a wise investment on our
part yes but uh I think so right now
oh I will update my Robin Hood portfolio
because you know I put like literally
ten dollars in a Robin and just like
play around with it you're gonna go for
Disney yeah okay
I'm down with Robin Hood man I'm down
with Disney I I feel like it Disney it's
not like steel but they definitely are
always innovating and frozen is is you
know it's what's the word like
progressive you know yes they're
evolving with the time you realize that
some of the things that they used to do
our backwards and they're not sticking
to their guns Victoria's Secret right
like they have their first openly gay
character on one of their new shows
Disney yes yep um I won't be updating my
Robin Hood to include a stock in
Victoria's Secret oh no because they're
there I don't see a future for Victoria
Souter but I'll tell my analyst over at
Robin Hood I'm down for Disney I just
need to invest in more I don't know more
corporate no no no more stable stocks I
just my portfolio is busted open at the
seams like I feel like now I need
glasses and like a calculator in my
briefcase - always a calculator
no Robin Hood is good and it's legit for
someone like me who knows nothing about
stocks investments bonds whatever but
also like knows how to use a phone you
know but also is hosting a morning show
where we are getting into business news
every day yeah I'm seeing what's going
on in the market it's helpful for us to
know like what to pick right and so I
feel like we actually have more
information than the average smell
anyway yeah and they don't take
Commission on Robin Hood which I love
because everyone has their hand in my
pocket these days and Robin Hood does
not like there's no fee associated with
the money that they make you and like
that is a dream like god that's
something I can trust
yeah no I'm I'm gonna go through my
stack before Leo so I want to look at
some stocks that aren't so like
mainstream like you know the big
companies Amazon right Facebook whatever
but we need to that's what they call
diversifying your portfolio and I'm
going to diversify it's really easy to
use it's not like difficult but the
charts and the numbers and the
percentages it's just like simple if
we're a simple steed it's simple to
understand and it can be easy for you to
understand as well because Robin Hood is
giving our listeners a free stock like
Apple Ford or Sprint to help build your
portfolio you can sign up at toast dot
Robin Hood dot-com that's toast dot
Robin Hood com
kill it kill it make some money and then
send it my way because like I gave you
the recommendation and like the free you
know stocks like I want I want to
commission maybe you were gonna embed
advice
in a cell phone company which one would
you what do you think it's gonna be the
one that's gonna shoot up like between
the experiencing mobile responsive love
me it's a responsible of me to give
stock advice honestly okay even though I
did when I went on CNBC at the stock in
sheet shell have run out to buy snapchat
stock and I was right yeah or by Sanchez
I stock and then sell it Ben's dad
really went to my snapchat stock cuz
like it's he's like one [ __ ] so he's
like it's he thinks but he was like it
was what we do he was supporting us and
like with the kids and I was like Bert's
do not do it and I was right it's really
crazy like snapchat evolution I got a
new phone and they downloaded all my
apps and Sam Shah was one of them and I
didn't actually log into snapchat for
three weeks I don't even remember why I
did I must I think I looked really ugly
and I needed a filter like I don't even
if even if I need a filter like I won't
even think to go to snapchat it's it's
in my phone I could delete it and my
life would be the same that's so weird
because imagine saying that two years
ago no and I find it I feel sad about it
because I'm so grateful to snapchat
because they like revolutionized my
brand yes like I used to be just like a
meme account and they didn't know how to
evolve past that and then I just started
driving people to snapchat where I was
just like being funny and being myself
and people got to know Claudia and now I
do that on stories but like I couldn't
have done it without snapchat and like
I'm really sad and like even when
Instagram blew up snapchat and copied
everything they did I was a loyal loyal
snapchat person and we talk about this
all the time and I'm just gonna repeat
myself because I didn't want to give up
on the app that like changed my life and
then they they gave up on me
yeah focusing so much on getting like
BuzzFeed to write terrible articles
about armpit hair right and focusing so
much I'm like trying to land Miranda
Kerr you missed out on the rest of it
totally it's amazing what can happen
when you're trying to sleep with Miranda
Kerr or what can't happen is she affects
where you see Granger she was a while
ago
not for long she wasn't like a Heidi
Klum in suits but she was there for like
a bit and moved on with her life she's
weird like she's like a model but like
who never works now she doesn't need to
but like even before what does she do
Orlando Bloom yeah been like I'm a wife
for a while yeah oh and did she sleep
with Justin Bieber
she was Justin beat yeah she was at the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show that
justin bieber performed at which was
like so cute and he was so great back
then and I believe um he slept with her
and Barbara Palvin and
right he was like 16 unclear he looks
nice with men older women Kourtney
Kardashian I can't I can't either cuz
I'm so hungry and I'm getting to the
point now where I'm just like rambling
because my stomach is grumbling and we
have to go to the airport so very sadly
we have to bid you and you thank you all
so much for tuning into the morning to
us the Millennium morning show we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube and Facebook we
are gone on Monday so there's no live
show but we will be releasing finally
our exclusive episode with melissa gorga
we spoke to The Real Housewives of New
Jersey star last week caught up it was a
really fun episode she had a glass of
wine before and she was like a little
tipsy and it was really something
hilarious yes so make sure to catch that
on our podcast episodes were available
stitcher iTunes Spotify public radio
anywhere cashbox anywhere you can listen
to podcasts to make sure you're
subscribed and you leave your [ __ ] a
five star review because we would really
appreciate it you know we didn't even
talk about because of his height
reminding me toast cycle oh yeah we had
till recap what a night what a night oh
what a class what a class oh my god okay
so I was like I don't you so like oh I'm
like knocked down for it but I
especially wasn't talking yesterday
because I was so hungover from Charlotte
and by the time the class rolled around
I'd been dreading it literally all day
and when I got there I intended til I
get in the bike and like do it for a
minute I take a couple pictures and like
wait outside for everyone to finish and
it ended up doing the whole class like
obviously I took a couple breaks like
snapchat and just like catch my breath
it wasn't nearly as bad as I thought it
was gonna be the teacher was awesome
awesome she played great music she had
great energy she was she just kept
saying which like I feel like my problem
with SoulCycle is like that it's a cult
and it's like if you're a newcomer like
just [ __ ] you like just get it yeah
where it's like not like welcoming to
like people who are out of shape or like
new to don't know how to lock in their
stupid shoes and like don't know that
you even need shoes like it's not warm
to newcomers but like at this location
is Bryant Park location like only then
Isis people work there right all the
girls were like so worried about me they
like literally they set my seat up for
me they put my thing and they put my ass
in and they were like helping everyone
who was new and it was just so welcoming
to newcomers and it really was breaking
down the stigma that SoulCycle has
created for itself and for that I was
very grateful for the nice people who
worked there the class was not as I
wasn't as out of breath dying as I
thought it was gonna be the only thing
and I still have to complain about I
kept having to stop not because I was
out of breath and dying but because my
ass was hurting me and they need to fix
it and I have like a permanent red
inflamed [ __ ] right now because of it
it's a
thing the more you do it it goes away
but it's like who wants even get to that
point it's not like it makes the work
out better like like as if they're
trying to like help you something yeah
just make the seat come from more
comfortable it won't change anything
yeah look I was standing board which is
like heart like because I didn't want
sit yeah it hurts it beauty is pain but
this was so fun for me like I was doing
it at like taking it very seriously and
the songs were amazing cuz we got to
request songs and then there were all
the other songs just like obviously a
teacher who was in tune with like what's
right like she took our list of songs
realize what kind of music we were into
and worked with it accordingly and I was
screaming at the top of my lungs which
also gets you out of breath so I was
truly dying she put a shout you played
shallow as the song after arm so it's
like the hill and it's dark and the
whole class was screaming we were a core
it's like I was wondering how the people
outside what we're here because we were
above the music it was literally like 50
girls just being like in the shack in
the shallow and honestly I was thinking
cuz I remember ever forget Kelly Rowland
on x-factor when she had like a group of
girls that were her men took mentees she
had them get on the treadmill and sing
because that's the only way to not get
out of breath when you're performing is
to exercise while singing and it really
like was a good idea and it really made
me realize like how like if I ever want
to become a singer let something I have
to do and SoulCycle is the perfect thing
because you sing the whole time and
you're working out that's what I do
yeah and I'm like this is good for my
career it didn't prepare me because when
we did a karaoke cam toast like I've
never been so out of breath in my okay
we were drinking and like we were
jumping like animals like we were not
and I think that was it to you and we
were screaming like we weren't saying
okay there it was great we raised a ton
of money for to uh Gift of Life which is
just the best organization like I can't
say enough positive things about it and
if you weren't able to company one and
Joanie just like $1 the link in the
morning chose to Instagram bio is where
you can donate to our circle so if we
get credit you know we're up to like 3
grand it's really great so just help us
get where we need to go and thank you
all for tuning in we will see you on
Tuesday you can follow along this
weekend at Jackie O problems girl with
my job I'm so close to 3 million you
guys I could you
a taste I can taste it and hashtag is
live goes mi a if you just want to stalk
all of it
thank you all better trading some
premium content for our paper in channel
as always actually not on my bachelor
because we were just all too drunk to
drunk but now we have to but now we will
patreon.com slash the morning toast how
they wonderful weekend we love you
you